BASHEER TOME: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our session.
If you're here to learn
about the Daydream controller
and how to design and
develop for it, then,
well, you're in the right place.
We're going to be doing this
session in three main chapters,
how, why, and what.
We'll dive briefly into the
design of the controller
itself.
We'll then walk through the
technical concepts on how
to implement the controller,
support, and Unity in C++,
and then we're going to bring
Ryan Francisco on from Schell
Games to share what they've
learned and showcase over
a dozen mini games that they've
built in the past few weeks
that really help show what
this new input device can do.
So let's get started.
Hi.
I'm Basheer.
I'm a hardware
interface designer here
on the Google VR team and the
design lead for the Daydream
controller.
I'll be walking you
through the first part.
What are the most
important things
that we have learned
from Cardboard?
As you might have heard
in our other sessions
is that while VR
is great for gaming
and we've had so much fun
with a lot of the games
that we've played
so far, we really
believe that VR is going to be
great for so many other things
as well and has a ton of
potential as a computing
platform.
And that is what makes it
such a compelling experience
to a huge breadth of people.
And for many of these
people, the applications
that you're building
right now are
going to be some of their
first experiences in VR.
And so the more we
thought about that,
the more we realized
that we needed
to build a better, more
immersive, longer form
way for people to interact in
VR that didn't involve them
keeping their hand
up here on their head
on one singular
button like they do
with the more snackable
experiences of Cardboard.
So we made the
Daydream controller.
While it doesn't
literally float in the air
like it does on this
slide, it is something
that you can hold in
your hand that we've
been creating for our
new Daydream platform
to help connect people to
their environment in mobile VR.
It enables you to explore and
manipulate things naturally
in a 3D VR environment by
letting you directly point at
and click on objects, hold
a tool in the virtual world,
and navigate menus.
We've spent a lot
of time and energy
in order to create something
that is accessible and simple
enough for new users and people
of all kinds of interests that
enables everyone to express
themselves creatively,
directly, precisely,
intricately,
and that doesn't force
them to lug around
something huge and unwieldy.
The ultimate goal was
a powerful, simple tool
that fits right in your pocket.
So let's start from the top.
The Daydream controller has
a curved clickable touchpad
that allows people to make
both fine-grained manipulations
and quick swipes for
scrolling while still enabling
them to make click selections
without lifting their thumb.
How does that work?
Well, if you look closely at
the side of the controller,
we've achieved this by embedding
a tactile, clickable switch
directly beneath the touchpad
that allows the top housing
to elegantly flex when you
apply pressure with your finger.
And that's something
that shouldn't
be too unfamiliar for a
laptop touchpad users.
Then reachable just
below the touchpad
are two buttons, the Home
button and the Up button.
The recessed Home button
is reserved entirely
for the system.
Pressing it takes
people immediately back
to the Home world, while holding
it down for just a little
bit longer lets them
reorient their view.
The App button, as you
can guess from the name,
has its functionality reserved
entirely for app developers.
For example, you
could use it to enable
switching from a hammer to
a saw, more often than not,
to open up a menu,
or in some cases,
undoing a failed pancake flip.
And since your phone is
inside the viewer and audio
is such an important
part of VR, we've
got hardware volume
buttons directly
in your hand to make it so
that people can reach them
conveniently and quickly.
However, the most important
and foundational aspect
of the controller is its
ability to directly point
in 3D space around you.
We use a highly
calibrated 9-axis IMU
that combines and fuses
data from an accelerometer,
gyroscope, and
magnetometer to output
an absolute rotation
value in space.
This means that instead of
relying entirely on a touchpad
to scroll through lists
locked to your viewport
or turning your head
in every direction
to click on something, instead
you just point directly at it
with your hand and click.
And because it's
done on a chip, you
can do that anywhere
around you would,
be it straight
ahead, to your right,
or behind you and all
that without having
any need to lug around and
set up an external camera
or tracking system.
And because of this took both
leaps in design as well as
in hardware and
software, we've been
developing both in parallel
as a team together.
Here is one of our hacky,
early prototypes that we
had been using in development,
which because of its similarity
and its size, we lovingly
call the garage door opener.
And we and our various
teams around Google
had been using these to test and
prototype a lot of our software
and hardware stack.
But as we got deeper
into the project,
we realized we couldn't just
mail one of these to everyone
out there and we'd really
love for both everyone
here in person as well
as every other developer
out there to be able to
intimately incorporate
this input into your
development process
while creating your new VR apps.
So Bruno, [INAUDIBLE], and
I and a handful of others
found a scrappier, cheaper,
and more accessible way.
It's in your pocket.
Most modern mobile phones today
contain almost all the hardware
you need to replicate the
controller minus the click.
So we created an app, which
you'll be able to download soon
called shockingly, the
Controller Emulator.
And although the orientation
sensors might not
be as precise or as calibrated
as in our final hardware spec,
it should be a great
alternative to get off
the prototyping fast.
So with a second
phone, you'll be
able to start up the, app which
creates a hotspot and connects
to your viewer to broadcast
its input in real time.
And that said, because we're
working in a VR world that's
only tracked by a
rotation, you're
essentially blindfolded
while you're in there
and you're likely
holding a phone that's
way bigger than the
hardware controller specs.
So we've created
a sticker overlay
to help guide your fingers.
It's capacitive.
It comes off
cleanly, but it still
gives you just the right
amount of tactile feedback
to find the now real-sized
touchpad and buttons on screen.
We've got printable PDFs
for scissors and paper
as well as laser cutable
vector files and a link
to the sticker material.
And all of that
will be in the SDK
download itself as well as
online under developer site.
I've also got a batch of
them pre-made with me,
so after this talk I'll be
standing outside the tent
if you want to come grab
one or ask questions.
And Bruno, in the next
chapter, will show you
how to implement the
SDK and how to enable
you to use both this emulator
and the final hardware
in your apps and
switching between the two
should actually
be pretty seamless
and require almost
no code change.
But before I go, I
wanted to leave you
with a pretty simple question.
With the Daydream
controller, we're
incredibly excited
about the possibilities
that you'll come up with.
You could be holding a tennis
racket, a whisk, a Frisbee,
a steering wheel, and so
much more right your pocket.
So what will you make in VR?
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
BRUNO OLIVEIRA: All right.
In my section of the
talk, we're going
to be speaking a lot about code.
But what exactly is code?
Well, the way I like
to think about it
is that from the left
side, you have the user,
and say on the right side, you
have some abstract concept,
say, happiness.
Then the only thing that's
standing between those two
is the code that we write.
So that's why code
is such a big deal.
But before we talk
about code, let's
go briefly into the things
that you'll need to write code
for the controller.
So if you have the
controller on one side
and you have your
phone on the other,
how do these two
things communicate?
Does anybody have a guess?
Bluetooth?
Yeah, that's a great guess.
Yeah, more specifically it
is Bluetooth low energy.
So the phone talks
to the controller
to be able to flow
energy, and your app
is there sitting on the phone.
Now, if you're not exactly the
type of developer who wakes up
every morning
thinking, yeah, let's
write some low-level
Bluetooth code, don't worry,
you won't actually have to.
Because the Google VR
services is a layer
on the system that talks
to Bluetooth directly
to the controller so that
your app doesn't have to.
Instead, your app
interacts directly
with the Google VR SDK.
And the Google VR SDK
does all the hard work
of actually communicating
to Google VR services
and ultimately to
the controller.
The controllers are going to be
available later on in the year,
but if you want to start
developing it right now,
you can.
All you have to do is
assemble your own DevKit.
And your DevKit
consists of a viewer,
you also need a Nexus
6P as the phone,
and you'll need to install the
Android N Developer Preview
3 on that phone.
Instead of a real controller,
you can use a secondary phone
as a controller emulator.
So you need one viewer,
and you need two phones.
From the perspective of
development, not much changes.
You might be
worried though, do I
have to write code especially
for the emulator and then
will I have to
change everything?
No, because the
Google VR Service
deals with the
code that actually
speaks to the controller,
so in terms of SDK,
it's the same thing.
You don't have to worry
about whether or not using
the emulator or view controller
SDK comes in several
flavors and you can go today
to developets.google.com/vr
if you want to get started
developing right away.
So you don't need to wait
for the real controller,
you can start right away today.
Now, let's talk a little
bit about the features
of the controller which are
common regardless of the SDK
that you are using.
The controller has
five main features--
orientation, gyroscope,
accelerometer,
and it also has a touchpad,
and several buttons.
So let's go into a
little bit of detail
about each of those
features starting
with orientation, which is
perhaps the most intuitive one.
Orientation just means it's
where the controller is
pointing in space, in 3D space.
We like to call it
a 3 DoF controller,
not only because DoF
it's kind of a cool word,
but also because it means
3 degrees of freedom.
And which 3 degrees
of freedom are those?
That is the yaw, so
where you're pointing
the controller, the pitch,
also called elevation,
and the roll, which is
also called twist or bang.
So those three angles
are the 3 degrees
of freedom of the controller.
We represent those
using a quaternion.
And quaternions are interesting,
mathematical [INAUDIBLE].
In most cases, if you're using
a math library or a game engine,
you can treat them
as a black box
or more specifically a
blue box in this case,
because they essentially
encode a rotation
that you can apply to a vector.
But if you now looking
inside of quaternion,
it's not actually that hard.
It has a vector component
made up of x, y and z.
It also has a scalar component,
and it has a fifth component.
Does anybody know what the fifth
component of a quaternion is?
No?
It's magic.
Because that's the only way I
can believe in how they work.
Well, actually, at
least that's what
I thought in the beginning,
but then as I studied them,
I realized that the
scientific truth is
that they are only about 60%
magic, the rest of it is not.
We represent all
of our coordinates
in the right-hand
coordinate system,
so you have the x-axis
pointing towards the right,
you have the y-axis
pointing up, and you
have the z-axis pointing back.
So this is just a standard
textbook coordinate system.
Next we have the gyroscope.
The gyroscope
doesn't have anything
to do with where the
control is pointing,
it has to do with
how it's moving.
In particular, it encodes
the angular velocity
of the controller about
each of its local axis.
So just to give an
example, suppose
that you have the controller
sitting flat on your table
and it's rotating
counterclockwise slowly at one
revolution every 2 seconds.
So what would you read from
the gyroscope in this case?
Well, the x and z would
be 0 because it's not
rotating there, but
about the y-axis, what
would be the rotational
speed in radians per second?
If you guessed pi,
that is correct.
Now, did I choose these numbers
just to make this terrible pun?
No, not in any way.
That's a coincidence.
The accelerometer, of
course, measures the force
of acceleration
on the controller
about each of its local axes.
It is combined with gravity
just as on the smartphone.
So normally if a controller
is sitting on a desktop,
you're probably going
to be reading something
like 0.0, 9.8, 0.0 because
the force of gravity
is 9.8 along the y-axis.
If you ever read 0.0, 0.0,
0.0, you should be concerned
because it means that the
user is in outer space
or there is no gravity or
worse, that the user tossed
a controller out
the window and it's
in free fall towards the ground
in which case you might say,
rage was detected.
Would you like to
play an easier level?
Also order me a new controller.
And lastly, we
have the touchpad.
The touchpad is
that circular area
on the top of the controller.
It is a two-dimensional
surface, so we
chose to use x and
y very creatively
to represent the position of
the finger on that surface.
In order to represent
coordinates,
we think of it as a square and
we map 0, 0 to the top left
and 1, 1 to the bottom right.
It's important to notice
that the touchpad also
has a clicker.
So the user can both
touch the touch pad
and also apply some pressure
on it to make it click
and those two things
are different.
And the buttons
on the controller
are the Click button, which
is precisely this button
that the user presses when they
apply pressure on the touchpad.
And you also have
the App button.
The App button can
be used by your app
to do anything you want with
the menu or switching tools
or anything else you want.
We also have the Home button
on the controller which
is reserved for the system use.
For example, that's
how the user go
it goes back to the Home screen,
that little thing on the side
out of the Volume buttons, which
is also reserved to the system.
So the Click and the App buttons
are available to your app
and you can implement
anything you want with them.
Typically, a clicker will
be the primary action
in your app like painting,
drawing, shooting, selecting,
grabbing, or anything like that.
And the App button will
be some secondary action
or to be up a menu.
So once again, touch is
different from click,
and this is a very
important point.
And on the emulator, since
there is no such thing
as clicking a smartphone
screen, you actually
double tap to emulate the click.
And we're going to give you
these little stickers that you
can put on the
controller emulator
to get more of a tactile
feel of how it works.
Let's briefly go
into the C++ SDK.
Well, C++ is a great language.
It's my favorite language.
And the thing is, it's
a powerful language that
has some responsibilities
that come with it.
How does the sentence end?
With great power comes-- great
stack traces that you sometimes
have to debug.
But that's C++ and I like C++.
Hopefully, that
won't happen to you.
When your app is
talking to our C++ API,
it is actually talking to our
C API that lives in libgvr.so.
And the reason why we do a C
API instead of a C++ API is
because it's difficult to get
two compilers to agree on how
to compile C++.
So instead, the C++ API
lives entirely on your space
and it's just a wrapper
around the C API.
So you can use it without
worrying about compiler API
incompatibilities,
which is good.
Now, let's look at code.
If you have experience in
C++, you're thinking, oh,
that's a funny dialect of
C++, but no, it's Java.
It's because in Android,
everything begins in Java.
So on your onCreate function,
first thing you're going to do
is set the VR mode
enabled because that's
going to enable all
of the other nice VR
optimizations for your app.
Next, you have your
GVR layout, what
used to be called
a Cardboard layout.
You set the Presentation view
as you are used to doing.
And next, and this is
the important part,
you get the GVR native context.
So the GVR native
context is just
an opaque pointer
to a GVR context,
which is something
that you'll need
to initialize to control API.
When you're down
into the C++ land,
all you have to do is get
the pointer and then store it
somewhere because you'll need
it while initializing the API.
Speaking of which, after you
set your default options,
that's where you pass in the
pointer, on the init function.
Press the Options
and that pointer.
And then you can forget
about the pointer
because it's only being
used to synchronize
the controller and the headset.
After that, it's a very
low-maintenance API.
You just have to do some
oil changes once in a while,
and by oil changes, I mean
just call Pause and Resume
when your application
gets paused or resumed.
And next, you can view
the controller state.
Now, controller state is
probably the most complicated
part because it encodes all of
the states of the controller
at any given time.
So we put together a team
of very creative engineers
and told them to
come up with a way
to represent a structure that
would include the controller
state.
And what we came up with
is struct ControllerState.
It's just a struct
and it has data in it.
Also we made the creatively
named ReadState method
that reads the state.
And it's that simple
because it doesn't
need to be more complicated.
On your draw a frame method,
on your rendering logic,
you're going to call
ReadState, and that gives you
the latest known state
of the controller,
and then you can process
that state in render.
How do you do that?
Well, the state has a few such
as orientation, gyro, accel,
and those just mean the current
readings of the various answers
in the controller.
For a touchpad, we have
an is_touching Boolean
that tells you if the user is
currently touching the touchpad
or not.
And we also have what
we call the event
Booleans or the
transient Booleans,
and those of the
Booleans that tell you
that a certain
event just happened.
And those are true
for only one frame,
so when you render your frame,
that's going to be true.
Next time you render
your frame, it's
going to be false,
because it just represents
something that just happened.
The user has just started
to touch the touchpad
or just stopped
touching the touchpad.
And of course, you also have
the touch position in x and y
as we explained before.
Button states work in
a very similar way.
So you have the Click
button and the App button.
You also have the state and
you also have the event.
Recentering is
what the user does
when they notice that the
headset and the controller
are drifting apart, so
they're no longer centered
or when they have just
picked up the headset
and it's facing the wrong way.
So there's a gesture that they
can do to make both of them
recenter and that's
holding the Home button,
pointing forward for about 1
second, and then releasing.
And then both the headset
and the controller
will be recentered to the
same coordinate system.
So before and after.
Basically, if before
the coordinate system
had diverged,
after, they're both
going to be pointing forward.
And you can know
that the user is
recentering by looking at
recentering or recentered
variable.
You don't actually
need to do anything
because the coordinate systems
are handled by the SDK,
but if you want to, you can
have access to those variables.
You might want to
pause the game,
for example, when the
user is recentering.
Next we have API status.
API status just tells you about
the general health of the API.
SO we have kControllerApiOK
means everything's going well.
There's ApiUnavailable if
the service is unavailable,
ClientObsolete if the
client is obsolete,
ServiceObsolete if the
service is obsolete,
and ZombieApocalypse if
there's a zombie apocalypse
and the undead are
taking over the planet.
Just kidding.
That one doesn't exist.
The controller will
continue to work
in case of a zombie apocalypse.
Connection state is
just whether or not
the controller is connected
to the phone right now.
So there's disconnected,
there's scanning, connecting,
and connected.
The best state is connected.
And I'll tell you how
later, but this has
to do with saving the world.
More on that later.
And you can download
the demo app
and look at code that actually
does all of those things.
Let's quickly look
at the Unity SDK.
In Unity, just as you did
before with the Cardboard SDK,
you import unitypackage
into your Unity Project.
Once you do that,
you'll notice that there
is a prefab under Assets,
Prefabs, Controller
called GvrControllerMain.
And all you have to do is drag
that prefab into your scene
and then have access
to the controller API.
In Unity, you normally
edit things in the editor
and then only after
you're happy with it,
we actually deployed
it to the device.
And we support that
use case because you
can plug in the
controller emulator
directly to your
computer via a USB cable
and have it work
during the Edit mode.
And then once you're happy, you
can deploy it to your phone,
and then it's going
to work via Wi-Fi.
Let's take a look
at an example code.
Let's suppose that
I have an object
and I want that object to match
the pose of the controller.
All I need to do is set
the object's local rotation
to the controller's
rotation by calling
a Gvr.Controller.Rotation.
It's that simple.
Suppose now that
you want to have
a vector that represents where
the control is pointing at.
Again, we just have to multiply
something by Vector3.forward
and that something is just
GvrController.Orientation.
That's what you
multiply and then
you get a vector that
points in the same direction
that the control is
going to be pointing at.
Now, let's do some raycasting.
Suppose you have a game
where the user is trying
to select an object in 3D
space using the controller
as if it was a laser pointer.
Again, you just get a
vector from the controller
and then do the
usual Unity Raycast
to figure out which
object was hit.
So the API is very
straightforward.
Lastly, we also have a
Gyro and Accelerometer,
and those are just
reporting that format
that we described before.
And you have the touch, which
works just like the C++ SDK.
IsTouching is whether or not
the user is touching currently,
and there's TouchDown
and there's TouchUp.
Same thing for buttons, all
the same logic ClickButton,
ClickButtonDown, ClickButtonUp.
Yes, Click is the name of
the button, the App button,
AppButtonDown and Up.
And then we have, of course,
the GvrController.State.
Same thing, Disconnected,
Scanning, Connecting,
and Connected.
Oh, yeah, and I had
promised to tell you
why that has anything to
do with saving the world.
Imagine that you have
a game where you're
trying to save that nice
little planet there,
that is just exactly like Earth.
And suppose that there
is this evil enemy.
Let's say you're trying to
defend it from the moon.
That makes no sense.
Let's say it's something
that's definitely not a moon.
So you're trying to
save it from that enemy.
And just as you are in
the final boss battle,
the player is about to deal that
final blow and save the planet.
Then what happens?
Of course, the controller
disconnects, and then
they are sitting there, and they
are not able to do anything,
and that's the end of
humanity as we know it.
And because we like
humanity and we should,
this is how you save it.
Any time the Gvrcontroller.State
is anything other
than
GvrConnectionState.Connected,
that's when you should,
for example, pause the game
and let the user reconnect
the controller instead
of continuing to play.
So we talked a whole bunch
about all the features
of the controller.
We talked about our
SDKs, and again,
you can go to
developers.google.com/vr right
now and you can download the
SDKs and the emulator app
if you want so you can get
started developing today.
In the beginning,
I showed you this,
but actually lied a little bit.
That's not 100% true.
The only thing that's standing
between user and happiness,
it's not just code.
There's more to happiness
than code, surprisingly.
You actually need design.
And if you're asking, what's
the difference between code
and design, the way I
like to think about it
is that code is when you're
doing the thing right,
and design is when you're
doing the right thing.
So in order to talk to
you a little bit more
about how to do
the right thing, I
would like to welcome Ryan and
Francisco from Schell Games.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCISCO SOUKI:
Thanks very much.
Hello, everyone.
Name is Francisco Souki.
I'm a Game designer
at Schell Games
in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
RYAN HIPPLE: And
I'm Ryan Hipple.
I'm a programmer
at Schell Games.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: And
we've spent a little
over a month just making cool
stuff for the controller.
We've made 17
demos, and our goal
was to just play around
with the controller,
see what feels
right, and we were
using the same tools that
would be available to you
today if you were to
develop right on Nexus 6P
and the headset and an emulator
controller and on Nexus 5
and using Unity to
make all of our games.
So we're going to take you
through some of the demos
that we made and we
learned a lot from
and tell you a little bit
about the design on my side
and the code on Ryan's side.
And to start, I will say that
like you heard these guys say,
this controller has a lot of
sensors, it has a lot of data,
it gives you a lot of power.
And me, as a designer,
when I saw this,
I was like, this
looks cool, I guess.
Ryan, you know how to
interpret all this stuff,
so my vision for this is, I
have a controller in my hand.
Can we just make something
that feels to the player
like they're holding
something like they're
holding the controller?
RYAN HIPPLE: Of course.
How about a game of tennis
or brick-breaking game
or what if we just
combine those two
and made a tennis
brick-breaking game?
So our Tennis demo, we're using
the orientation quaternion
from the controller to control
the rotation of a tennis racket
that pivots around the
body of the player.
And we have a very natural range
of the tennis racket that way
where you can do your
forehands and backhands,
and it's always rotated
around the right spot.
On the more game
design side of this,
we are focusing on leveraging
the very accurate orientation
we get from the SDK and using
that to make sure that when you
hit the balls, you're either
directing them upward if you're
tilting your wrist up or down if
you're tilting your wrist down,
and you can make them go
to the left or the right.
So in order to do
that, we're actually
cheating the collisions
in this game a lot
to make the game easy to
hit, and we're actually
putting the game
challenge in there
by forcing the player to use
that accurate aim in order
to twist their wrist to get
the ball exactly at the panel
that they want to smash.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: Yes.
So like Ryan said, in this
game, it's all in the wrist.
We did a little bit of timing
so that if you swing early,
it will go that way,
if you swing late,
it will go that way.
But you don't have to worry
about the position of the ball
and how to hit the ball,
it's more about your
aiming with the wrist.
It was very fun.
The playtesters
loved it or shall
I say the playtesters that
love skill games loved it.
The playtesters who maybe
aren't fond of tennis
or don't like skill games,
they weren't so hot on it.
So my immediate thought
there was, well, why don't we
try some more traditional motion
kind of like gesture detection
and see how they
feel about that.
RYAN HIPPLE: Of course.
So in our more traditional
motion control game,
we have our warrior game, which
you can see in this video here,
players try to slash at objects
before they hit a warrior
avatar.
And we're using this by
actually just detecting
a few simple gestures
with the controller,
and we're using the
gyroscope readings here.
The gyroscope readings
are the perfect thing
for this because
they're going to tell us
how fast the player is
moving the controller.
So once their movement speed
is exceeding some threshold
that we need to use,
we'll figure out
exactly what direction
that's going,
and we'll quantized
that into a left,
right, up or down slash
and use that to power
an avatar that has a sword
and gets to break stuff.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: So
this works, but you
do get a little bit of that
kind of like I'm standing here
swiping effect, which is how
every other sword game before
has been made in a
gesture-based motion control.
And our players who had
tried the tennis first
were like, I want
that one to one.
Why are you giving me gestures?
So Ryan, is there anything
we can do to this game
to get some of that
one to one back but not
compromise the core mechanic?
RYAN HIPPLE: Yes, there is.
This is where we can one up
traditional motion control
games because we have
that accurate orientation
quaternion.
So by maintaining the
gameplay that we already
have with the slash gestures,
we can use the orientation
to power the animation on
this character in the scene.
And we use that to blend
between several animations
or several poses, and the
sword on this warrior character
should always be reflecting the
orientation that a player is
holding the controller.
Additionally, one issue
with our first approach
was if you would
swipe to the left,
you would do a sword
slash to the left,
but if you're twisting
your controller, that's
now an upward swipe.
So you can get around
that by multiplying
or by transforming
your gyroscope readings
by the orientation,
which will give you
something that's more of a
world space slash detection.
So no matter how they're
twisting the controller,
it's always going
to slash according
to the movement of the player.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: Yes.
So you can definitely take
those gesture controls
to the next level.
But I wanted to go back
to that one to one,
that holding an
object in my hand
and examining it
and trying it out,
and I was hoping maybe
instead of aiming far away,
we could give them, the players,
something that's a little more
close range to play with.
RYAN HIPPLE: So in
our Xylophone demo,
we let players play
a massive xylophone
with a massive hammer.
Why not?
Here we're actually
taking the orientation
and splitting it up into
different components
and treating each of
those axes differently.
So swinging the
hammer up and down,
we're using the pitch
axis or the x-axis,
and that's powering the position
or the rotation of the hammer.
And we keep a little bit of
a constraint on that so it
doesn't clip through the keys
and it doesn't break immersion.
We're using the
ability to point,
so this would be the heading
or the yaw of the controller,
in order to aim at
what keys the player is
going to hit to play what
notes they want to play.
On top of that, we're
using a little bit
of the camera's rotation.
So you'll notice in the video
here that the field of play
is much broader than what you
can see with just one screen.
So turning your head,
you can look to the left
or to the right, and were using
that to cheat a little bit
and make sure that
the player is going
to hit the thing that they're
focusing on so that when
they're moving
their hand quickly,
they don't end up throwing off
the direction of the hammer.
So we're doing a little bit
of aim assist in this game.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: Yeah.
And in this demo, you can
tell the players are starting
to feel, things start to gel.
They love manipulating
a closely-held object,
and you can usually [INAUDIBLE]
watching them play, watching
them go through three stages.
The first stage is,
they jump in the world,
they see they're
holding a hammer,
and they do the wrist thing, and
the hammer does the wrist thing
for them, so that's great.
The controller is
working perfectly there.
Then they realize the keys
are in a curved shape,
so they look around.
So they're using that sort of
VR space, looking all around.
And then they identify
any key they want to play,
and they go for the
boop, and it works.
So it's a combination
of where you're looking
and how you're swinging,
and when that feels right,
when the world holds up to what
they want to do as players,
it feels great
for them, and then
that's where the
platform really shines.
So that combination
of head orientation
and controller action helped
improve their perceived
accuracy.
And so I'm thinking,
well, can we
use that combination
of that aiming
and that closely-held object
to maybe let them do something
that they wished they could do,
but they can't do in real life.
RYAN HIPPLE: If anybody
who's here actually tried
to throw a boomerang--
has anybody ever tried
to throw a boomerang?
It's incredibly disappointing.
There's a very, very, I
guess, powerful technique
that is only mastered by a few.
It's really sad.
You throw it, it
doesn't come back.
It doesn't go where
you want it to go,
it just kind of wobbles around.
But there's this expectation
of what a boomerang does.
You see that shape
and you feel like, I
should be able to throw this.
It should be able to go
exactly where I want it to
and have it snap
right back to me.
So this is where we
take the orientation
that we get from
the headset, again,
and we use this
as an aim assist.
So where the player is
looking in this demo
is going to drive where the
curve of this boomerang goes.
And the goal here is to break as
many of these floating targets
at once with a single throw to
kind of get that ideal path.
So since we're using
the head for aiming,
we now have the controller
free to do our throwing.
And we're using
the similar thing
we did for the
sword slashes here
where we're using the
gyroscope readings
and if it's above a
certain threshold,
it's going to trigger the throw.
So just looking where
you want to throw
and doing your throw
gesture is going
to get that boomerang out there.
Additionally, to maintain a
little bit of immersion here,
we're using the orientation to
make sure the boomerang rotates
to reflect the rotation
of the controller
at least when it's
in your hands.
And you can see
that in the videos
here, just that little
bit of ambient movement
just is keeping it grounding the
player between the two worlds.
FRANCISCO SOUKI:
So like Ryan said
this video is about
empowering the player
and about letting them
experience their boomerang
fantasy, how they feel throwing
the boomerang should feel like.
So it's all about like, boom, I
want to put in that exit sign,
bam, it's going there.
So less about very precise
one-to-one matching of thing
they're pointing or
the exact hand movement
and more about the precise
matching and the boomerang
in their hand
combined with the aim
assist that the gaze
is providing us.
So it's all about interpret
all of that data that we get
and letting the player
sort of fulfill what
they think it should play like.
What we realized at
this point though is,
we hadn't touched
touchpad at all.
It was all about the swinging
and all about the pointing
and the head, and touchpads
are just the number one thing
you usually use in
games, whether it's
a joystick or a
virtual touchpad.
So we use touchpads all the
time for all of our games.
Can't we just put
something we normally
make in a normal platform, a
different platform, or a non VR
platform in this special
place with this touchpad?
Does it hold up?
RYAN HIPPLE: Of course, we can.
Using the touchpad that
we have on the controller,
we can use that as a
traditional D-pad controls.
And this is something
that players
are going to be immediately
familiar with because it's
the type of games that
had existed since, well,
almost the beginning of games.
So in our Adventure
Game demo, the player
controls a little
character walking
around using that D-pad.
And the nice thing
about this is,
it frees up-- the headset
now, functions as your camera
control, which is
generally a little bit
of a problematic control
scheme in Adventure Game.
So you can look around
the world and it
adds the sense of
exploration that you
can see more than you would
be able to if you had to have
this automatic follow camera.
Those controls
then, also we have
them a little bit specialized
for the layout here.
We were able to have this
character in an environment.
It circles the player
and their perspective.
So when you want to move the
character along that path,
we have it so that it's
almost a circular-based path.
You hold it to the
right on the D-pad
and the character
will trace a circle
around the player making
it much easier to navigate,
making it easier to make
the player move forward
through the world.
And of course, in
this demo, we have
it end up with
the player meeting
the character they've been
controlling this entire time.
We also use a little
bit of the gesture
controls that we talked
about before and the click
pad in order to use abilities
that can trigger things
in this environment and
have some light puzzles
and some collection
mechanics, as you can see.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: So
boy, does it hold up.
When you're making your
own adventure games,
you will realize that you can
use a touchpad for movement.
No problem.
It's going to feel great.
And it's going to free
up all the other stuff
in the controller for you
to explore that space.
So this is the extent of
the demo that we made.
Everything you're seeing
here is the totality
of the spaces we explored.
So what that leaves is a whole
lot of open space for you guys
to sort of take it to
the next level however
you feel like you want to.
So in this case, the click,
the gestures, the pointing, all
that is still freed up.
It's not something
that you need to use.
And the touchpad feels
familiar to the players.
It's recognizable,
so you truly can
use all of those interactions
because the player doesn't
need to think twice about
how to use a touchpad
to move a character.
Ryan, where did we take
it after we figured out
that the touchpad was
good for one character?
RYAN HIPPLE: Well, if
it's good for one player,
let's see if we can use it to
control multiple characters.
So in our Real-time
Strategy Style demo,
we're using the
orientation quaternion
that we get from the
controller, from the SDK
and using that to
recast into the world.
And you can use this to
point to select a character
and then point to
direct them somewhere,
and you can also drag select
to select multiple characters
in the world and give them
instructions at the same time.
You can also use the
gyroscope gestures, again,
like we did for the sword
slash and like we've
been doing for a
lot of the games
to trigger multiple actions
that these characters can do.
And in this, we have a few
simple puzzle mechanics
that lets the player
explore this world.
And again, you're using the
orientation from the headset
and taking control of the
camera very naturally with just
the player's look vector.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: And
boy, does point and click
feel good in this platform.
We love this demo.
Playtesters love this demo.
People couldn't put it
down until they figured out
the puzzle that we had,
and the interaction,
we're just empowering
them to control
the characters, how they wanted
to control the characters.
We also draw a line from
the assumed control position
to the target, and
that keeps players
aware of the orientation of
their controller at every time.
And that interfaces
make it really easy
for you to control one
character or several characters
and similar to
the adventure game
that you just saw before,
the touchpad game,
it frees up a lot of the
controller especially
because you can also use the
whole world, the whole 360
around the player to sort
of pace out your level
and to control where the
player is going to be looking
at any given time.
So that camera
movement doesn't need
to be tied to the
controller in every way.
So if your mind right
now is going, man,
how can you use a
mechanic to make an RTS
or to make a strategy
game, a tactics
game, any sort of
multi-character control game,
to that drag to select,
all that, that's
exactly where we should be going
because the platform is really
good for it.
What we thought was,
well, we'll figure out
how to sort of get the most
of those orientation controls,
how to get the most of
the character control.
Can we marry those two together?
RYAN HIPPLE: Of course, we can.
In our Skyship demo, the players
control a gliding airship
through an environment
where they're
dodging obstacles and trying
to pick up coins along the way.
This is actually pretty
simple on the input side
where we're just using the
orientation that we get.
This lets us essentially
just point and click--
or I'm sorry, no
clicking-- point
to guide this glider
around the environment
and using the yaw, the
pitch, and the roll
just like you would
with an actual aircraft
to get it to move
around this environment.
Having the roll or the twist
as well is really nice for this
because should the mood strike
you, you can do a barrel roll.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: Yep.
And Ryan said no clicking
because, again, the clicking
is freed up here for you
to do whatever you might
want to do on a flying ship.
When you play this,
it really feels
like you're kind of
handling a toy airplane.
You're kind of like
threading it through space
all through these rings.
The hand shake in this
is not a big problem here
because you control
how wide the gaps are
with the rings or the
spaces that you're
trying to fit the space ship
through or the ship through.
So that kind of counters
a lot of the imprecision
that your own hand translates
into the world, and it does
allow you to orient the
ship sort of however you
want as you're flying with it.
This is another one that
playtesters couldn't put down.
We just keep the rings coming,
and they will keep playing.
And so unless you give them
a goal of like elect 10 coins
and then please
pass it along, they
will just like stay in
there doing it all the time.
It feels good.
The pillars are there so that
you don't get that motion
sickness from moving forward.
You're stationary and the world
is moving in front of you,
so you're fine.
You don't get that
motion sickness.
And at that point, we're
feeling pretty confident
and we're like,
all right, we seem
to have this flying
thing figured out.
It's constrained to
a plane, but maybe we
can break out of that plane.
Maybe we could go
a little bigger.
What I want to do is,
I want to feel like,
not like I'm flying
a kite, but like I'm
controlling this giant
creature that I just summoned.
RYAN HIPPLE: Here
be the dragons.
In our Dragon demo, the player
controls a massive dragon
using, again, the
controller orientation,
and they're pointing this, the
controller, in the direction
that they want the dragon to go.
To give a little bit of
an immediate feedback,
we have a little dollar, a
statue of the dragon positioned
in front of the camera
so the player can see
what the goal orientation is.
And this is another
thing that we've
learned in the
other demos where we
want to maintain a relationship
between the controller
and some physical object
in the environment.
Then in order to
make the dragon feel
like it's this
massive entity, we
have that point
towards that vector
that you're guiding
it towards and have
it sort of lumber along in
this long, twisting path,
collecting and destroying
those floating objects.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: Yeah, but
this one feels really good.
When you get the source
to play with all of these,
just fire up this Dragon demo,
point the controller yourself,
and watch the
dragon come at you.
And we've got a bunch
of things in there
to sort of take
advantage of that VR.
There's a slight
camera shake, which
sounds kind of
like, what, you're
shaking the player's camera?
But don't let anyone ever tell
you what you can't do in VR.
Try it and see if it works
or not because it works here.
It's a slight shake.
It's combined with the
positional audio of the dragon
so that you really feel
like you're sharing
a space with this big creature.
And you're kind of doing
this dance with it.
It's big and it's
heavy and it handles
like a big, heavy creature.
So you're kind of like
dancing with it through space,
and you're trying to eat up
all these big structures.
Then you point it at yourself,
and it's coming at you.
And there's this thing next
to you and it tries to eat,
and you're like, oh, my god.
It's great.
It feels really good.
This is really, I think,
showcasing what Daydream
can do, which is a lot,
especially when you combine
the headset with the
controller and you
get those epic fly overs with
the dragon, it feels great.
So at this point,
we're like, all right,
we did the dragon thing,
the boomerang thing,
the xylophone to play the
music, a bunch of other stuff.
We have 17 in total and
what's left for us to do?
Should we really give
the people what they've
been asking for all along?
RYAN HIPPLE: You've
seen it already.
You've seen it plenty.
Here be the pancakes.
In this demo, we're actually
using the orientation
to flip these pancakes.
Then we have a very advanced
pancake physics engine
that we're running to make sure
the pancakes are moving around
as they should.
In reality, it's actually just
using the basic game physics
system here.
And having a pan that
has the lip on it
as the collision
structure, it actually
works really, really well.
This orientation gives you
that really nice flip gesture
that you can do.
And we're not really
doing a gesture detection.
When I say gesture, it's
just sort of natural
how the physics
simulation pairs up
with having this raw
orientation input.
And it turns out to be a
very, very fun thing to do.
We did do a little
bit of active pancake
assist here to make sure
the pancakes don't get
with out of reach,
but overall, it's
just a very natural fun demo.
FRANCISCO SOUKI: Yeah.
I do think the
Pancakes sort of fit
what is awesome about Daydream,
which is, you see the Pancakes
demo, you've been reading like
people are tweeting about it
from the Keynote and all.
It's like oh, my god, I
want to flip pancakes in VR.
And you get in there and
you flip pancakes in VR
and it plays how it looks.
You're flipping pancakes in VR
and you're like, yes, got it.
So when the platform
allows you to do
exactly what it looks like, it
feels like what it looks like
and what it should feel like,
that's when it's a big win.
So forward to Ryan for
some final thoughts
on developing all
these awesome demos.
RYAN HIPPLE: What if we
could eat pancakes in VR?
FRANCISCO SOUKI:
That's the next step.
RYAN HIPPLE: Francisco mentioned
at the beginning of our section
that we built 17 demos,
so 17 demos like these,
and we did that in a
little over a month.
All of the tools that
we had to do this
were the SDK that Bruno and
Basheer talked about and using
the controller emulator
where you're actually
using a phone as your input
device and a Nexus 6P.
We were using a Cardboard
to develop with.
So all of these
things are out there
and they're available now.
And the source code for all
of the demos that we've built
should be available
soon for people
to play around with and
use as a starting point
to jump in and start making
great games with this platform.
We really feel like
the things that we
put together only really
scratch the surface of what
we can do with Daydream
and what we can do
with this amazing controller.
So what will you build?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]